e siamo in diretta max ciao ciao max io
le mie sorelle barbie state i celti
cerchiamo il centro trovatelli delle
sorelle robert che vedete alle mie
spalle
raga ma sta scherzando questo business
che può essere anche molto divertente ma
ero in tarda eta ma ti do il dietro le
quinte così scoprirete di cosa si parla
ragazzi non ce la posso più fare va bene
tutto a un certo punto stavo morendo
dentro i ragazzi bene solo fine se lo
fai j game player più energetico e
portata dei contenuti migliore su
youtube.it a e grazie a tutti barbie e
le sue sorelle salvataggio cuccioli
questo ci avevo giocato 1600 anni fa
grazie a dio non c'è più salvataggio che
si possa evitare fare la figura di cacca
chiamo kimberly ma io non vedevo l'ora
amica mia
tra l'altro ragazzi è un gioco ed è
tanto che non mi succedevano vergine che
non ha le opzioni c'è tutto lo devi
tenere così scorrere la mappa no io
posso usare il joystick o sun side ma
addirittura mi stai facendo questo
regalo io posso usare il joystick per
giocare ragazzi gta 5 per sono guarda
guarda invece la gente queste gta queste
gta family friendly punto bene ragazzi
allora siamo salvataggio cuccioli ciò
vuol dire che devo salvare i cui cosa
devo fare
mamma mia come se adrenalinica provare
le macchine ei dj mad può comunque
questo è cucciolandia no deve stare qua
si può entrare è permesso sceglie la
bici ma si scende dalla bici scende
dalla bici per favore a obiettivo guarda
intorno città per i cuccioli smarriti io
devo trovare i cuccioli smarriti ragazzi
devo cercare in giro per la città i
cuccioli smarriti
è l'obiettivo del quindi cerchiamo i
cuccioli smarriti lì c'è un manifesto
per cucciolo smarrito andiamo posso
salire qua sopra
non ci posso salire giustamente perché
non è la pista ciclabile scelta sopra
andando indietro hanno messo la
retromarcia ragazzi ma che giovi
incredibile devo andare a trovare quel
cucciolo smarrita andiamo ragazzi a non
pensavo che gta se fosse così ben
dettagliato se ci pensate molto più
saturato di gta 5 c'è veramente preso
bene
ok ci sono ok sono uscito non so anche
come ho fatto
questo dovrebbe aiutarmi a trovarlo
guarda intorno a casse e scatole per il
cucciolo smarrito gunner ama davvero
nascondere nelle scatole ama davvero
nascondere nelle scarse lui nasconde le
cose ma c'è la freccia ma mi dice dove
sto andando la mio dio che c'ha leggere
posso scalare gli oggetti non posso
scalare gli oggi vanno adesso si
inscrive questo allora ragazzi devo
andare devo cercare gunner gunners io lo
so che tu ami nascondere però non
nascondere adesso perché mi servi
possono rubare questa bici posso rubarla
no ma questo è successo
spa nata la mia bici va bene ragazzi
devo andare a trovare gunner che stava
non so dove però forse le scale interne
qua non posso andare fuori strada in
questo gioco mamma mia quanto family
friendly cioè praticamente questo e come
dovrebbero essere i videogiochi
secondo studio aperto ma viene da
ragazzino no ma io questa cosa me la
devo dire non so se vi rendete conto ma
quando c'è la discesa adesso vi faccio
notare vedete che adesso lei pedala
quando c'è la discesa a signori lei
smette di pedalare perché stai andando
in discesa guarda c'è ma incredibile
ragazzi i videogiochi negli anni hanno
fatto passi enormi gunner hai qualche
aspetta che qua che ama nascondere fermi
e zitti
mi scusi devo passare è che il misero
incastra togliti tu gunner sei qui sono
arrivati sono in atto da gunner ragazzi
gunners ho trovato lo so che ami
nascondere pro ti devo trovare che è
successo ma mamma mia se sta diventando
difficile ragazzi a voi farmi proprio
girare un sacco se non mi incastrarsi in
un palo ogni 4 secondi o adesso dovrebbe
essere qua cannero al 50 per cento di
possibilità o sopra o sotto vediamo era
sotto vediamo cosa riesco a fare se il
parcheggio qua vediamo un attimo eccoci
ci siamo
gunners ecco dentro dove che sta aned e
ci si è comparsa una scatola convincere
i gunners di uscire allo scoperto
ragazzi dobbiamo cominciare gunner di
uscire mamma mia
ma sei proprio tu diventato
difficilissimo questo gioco incredibile
allora il tasto giu no ok colosso
prendiamo un'altra roba vuole i cuori
metti liquori bravissima ancora un'altra
cosa fare attenzione non sbagliare
questi de vita o di morte bravissima
l'adrenalina re corpo ha fatto moore a
posto
ragazzi questo il nostro ritorno al
canile si gunner facevo di vedere chi ha
il culo più grosso vai le rapine in
banca zia quelle sì cosa sta facendo lo
sta scippando sta giocando nintendogs
lei gunner ti devo vaccinare scusami
certo certo premi a più eletti per
strada il vaccino
grazie estraendo il bacino al tatto le
faccio con un sì certo i cani sono
proprio così precisi la guerra visto
negli occhi 10 ossa di ricompensa
andiamo avanti
non lo so di fare un incidente avere
andiamo a salvare un altro cucciolo
vediamo dove si possono salvare sé che
non c'è niente quado trovare un altro
manifesto ei franklin è un'altra
missione per me voglio esser centro
città cerca il cucciolo border collie no
ragazzi questo è difficile convincere il
border collie di venire da te con
vinciamo lo di venire a novoli cuoricini
come fatta finire nei cespugli cercava
dove pisciare a quanto dovrò fare lo
youtube ci sono dei momenti in cui io mi
fermo e dico caro il mio lavoro mi
rispecchia proprio come persona il mio
border collino
ok è il codice per spalare il carro
armato riporta il cucciolo border collie
al canile let's go
meno male che siamo già qua così messo
solo due persone perfetto mamma mi ha
pensata invece se facessi la youtuber
povera skipper si vede arrivare cani da
un momento all'altro
[Musica]
terminator ha bisogno di cure dentali
rimuovere la placca dei suoi denti
riempire tutte le cavità che trovi va
bene leo riempire i denti termine che li
metteremo infetto allora perché c'è un
dense grecia colorazione e sarai come
nuovo ok dentista dei cani dove è in
buone mani col cielo o un'altra
telefonata di benjamin franklin
speriamo che mi chiede di incontrare
trevor cosa devo far saltare il ponte
all'impazzata
quanta energia è meglio che lo trovi ma
non vedo l'ora
o perché cos'è il border collie si è
persone le fognature aiutano a trovare
la via d'uscita
no ragazzi a questo un enigma sim pazzo
che fognature sono spiegami ma cos'è
dark souls è fermo che non capisco che
l'uscita ma l'uscita e lì sopra ma che
perdono l'avevo vista averlo nuovo vista
sul serio
per una volta uno sto scherzando avevo
visto gente questo gioco è difficile
power coccola il numero di power
bastava bayan nasca come ha fatto
arrampicarsi sulla scala scusami
l'importante che ne siamo consapevoli e
che riusciamo ad andarci in giro allora
si guardava strada tu perché mi devo
guardare dietro perché non sei venuta in
italia se no a quest'ora ero già dentro
casa con la bicicletta
porca vacca seguire le regole questi
americani poi dai parcheggi in mezzo
alla strada dai non è un parcheggio ana
è un parcheggio strano sta questa città
comunque certo che gli fa dei soldi è
guasta guardali che macchina ma voglio
andare a casa vagoni quello chiamiamo
così felice che il microchip
meno male mai aperto che funziona come
appena detto sono contenta che il
microchip funzioni non funziona
microchip vabbè siccome veniva dalla
fogna al ragazzo dobbiamo trovare un
nome che gli si adeguino come persona
quindi
lord fognatura lavoro non è di lord e
fognatura le pulci ben mazza ma guarda e
miracolo che non abbia gli scarafaggi
radioattivi rimuovere le pubblicità il
cucciolo utilizzare il trattamento delle
pulci per fornire protezione contro i
parassiti risolveremo tutto
sì per carità sei stato solo sotto la
foglia per otto anni ma perfetto
mamma mia se avessi giocato a fallout
queste cose sarebbero più grosse del
cane ma fa niente a posto a posto smetti
di grattarti non c'è più ancora 2 in 1
ho fatto un collateral desk riesci ossa
ragazzi cosa ci compro queste ossa che
non 30 ora abbiamo lord e fognatura
terminator
e poi c'è il board c'è gunner che era
chalayan nome purtroppo abbiamo finito
basta noi possiamo stacco a tutta la
vita passa qualcuno se lo adotta vi
prego
mamma mia udito tre cani sono passati
tre cani come il dizionario credo di
aver fatto tutto tutto tu alettato fatto
adottare tutto tranne che adesso non
posso per cercare che qui ho finito il
gioco riconoscimenti ragazzi questa era
questa è la stanza di donald trump però
io ho finito barbie salvataggio cuccia
licenza sfiderà però che vi sia piaciuto
se avete bisogno di consigli su come toy
dettare i cani su come salvare i cani su
come addestrare i cani già schemi e io
arrivo e ricordatevi che se avete un
cane dovete prendervi ne cura tutti i
giorni comprando le cose con le ossa se
la gente vuole i soldi chi sta fregando
le cose si comprano con le ossa
però vi sia piaciuto lasciando me mi
piaci schieder e chiara ricliccate la
campanella per che non vorreste mai
perdere
e noi ci vediamo come al solito e non
fossimo video da ragazzi
[Musica]
ma